un fenómeno al que los cubanos
residentes en la isla no están
acostumbrados la inflación llegó con la
reforma monetaria implementada en 2021
en el proceso el peso cubano pasó de 24
a unos 120 por cada dólar con el
objetivo de equilibrar la diferencia el
gobierno aumentó los salarios y las
pensiones eso era bueno la idea de la
subida de salarios para los que los
precios Son los que están por el cielo
no acompañan con el salario a veces esto
además dificulta el acceso a diferentes
productos alimenticios
Xiomara vive de la llamada libreta de
abastecimiento una fórmula gubernamental
implementada durante décadas para
contrarrestar la escasez alimentaria
pero hoy la diferencia de los productos
que vienen incluidos en ella es notable
yo lo que compro el pollo que siempre
viene por el que te dan el pollo y eso
es lo que como pollo es como más Pollo
que otra cosa porque es lo que más te
dan y ya a mí el pollo en sí no me gusta
a mí yo prefiero comerme un huevo un
pollo pero bueno como no tengo otra cosa
tengo que comer lo que haya la inflación
ha hecho que muchos acudan en las
remesas el envío de estas a Cuba
principalmente desde Estados Unidos
ayuda a la economía nacional la tasa de
cambio de uno a 170 para poner un
promedio es muy estimulante para todo el
que reciba Divisas externas entonces una
persona que uno puede pensar bueno
Estados Unidos me mandan 200 dólares no
es mucho sí pero 200 dólares son cinco
veces salario promedio que pagar el país
mientras eso pesan los efectos que
tendría una eventual recesión global la
economía cubana también trata de
recuperarse de su más reciente lastre
los daños que le dejó la pandemia al
turismo una de sus principales fuentes
de ingresos